console can be identified with some
Precision because Mrs Graham had just
stepped off the number 13 bus which was
known to have arrived at that bus stop
at 9 43 give or take a minute
you David Boyd must have been close by
when that encounter took place
by 9 51 PM another timing which can be
identified with precision
you were seen with Nikki outside the
mcfish factory on the lower High Street
in Hendon he was striding ahead whilst
Nikki trotted behind you trying to keep
Pace with you
it would have taken about three to four
minutes for you and Nikki Allen to walk
from the bus stop to the mcfish factory
you David Boyd were leading Nikki Allen
to the grounds of the old Exchange
building on low road a derelict building
surrounded by a walled area of rough
scrubland
he took her into that rough ground where
you sexually assaulted her or at least
attempted to do so
Nikki Was Heard screaming at around 10
p.m by Mrs Osborne who was in her flat
overlooking High Street East
you struck Nikki across the face causing
her lip to bleed you did this to shut
her up
before or after this there must have
been some sort of a struggle between you
as Nikki's anorak came off and she lost
both of her shoes
from the moment of her letting out those
screams Nikki's fate was sealed
you decided to kill her to silence her
and to prevent her from telling anyone
that you had sexually assaulted her or
had attempted to do so
you hoisted Nikki up the six or so feet
necessary to reach the window and pushed
her through a gap in the boarding into
the derelict old Exchange Building
inside the building was Pitch Black
the windows were boarded up say for one
missing board leaving a gap to which
Nikki had been pushed but in any event
it was late in the evening of an October
night
once inside Nikki must have been
petrified
it would not have taken the
seven-year-old long to appreciate that
she was trapped in that cold and dark
building and that you were coming
through the window to get her
the forensic scientists told the jury
that the sight of the Fatal assaults was
as far away from the window as Nikki
could have gobs on that ground floor
that is the far wall at the furthest
room
no doubt this is where she ran in order
to get as far away as possible from you
her fear as she saw you lurching towards
her in the dark is unimaginable
you found her standing or sitting
against that far wall it was there that
you struck her head at least twice with
a brick fracturing her skull into
several pieces
although not necessarily immediately
fatal those blows to the Head are likely
to have rendered Nikki unconscious
you then stabbed her naked chest and
upper body with a knife which you had
brought with you
it was a frenzied attack during which
you stabbed her 37 times
many of the stabs were inflicted through
the stain stab wound
the knife was described by the
pathologist Dr Cooper as having a
tapering blade of around 107 centimeters
long
you pushed the blade into her chest and
organs to its fullest extent so that her
body bore the marks at the hilt of the
knife
having killed her you then dragged Nikki
Allen by her ankles down the staircase
into the cellar of the old Exchange
building her head bouncing from stair to
Stair leaving traces of blood and fibers
on the risers
you dragged her into the far corner of
the furthest room and left her no doubt
hoping that her body would remain
undiscovered
your hope that Nikki would not be
discovered did not take into account the
extent of the concern that Nikki's
disappearance provoked in the tight-knit
community of the garths that complex of
tenement flat where Nikki and her family
lived
a large number of Nikki's family friends
and neighbors set about searching for
her
Nikki's body was discovered in the
basement of the old Exchange building
only the next morning by a local
teenager
in the police investigation which
followed the murder you were interviewed
by police officers conducting house to
house inquiries
you later gave a witness statement in
which you said that you had seen Nikki
playing in weirgarth earlier that
evening
you told the police that you'd been out
getting fish and chips between 9 30 and
10 p.m that evening so giving yourself a
need but holy false Alibi for the time
of the murder
in 1993 an innocent man George Herron
was tried and acquitted of Nikki Allen's
murder at Leeds Crown Court
as the years passed by and you got on
with your life
you must have thought often about
Nikki's murder
you must have thought No Doubt with some
satisfaction and some relief that you'd
got away with it
however the science of DNA analysis was
advancing
new developments led the police to
identify traces of why Str DNA which
matched your profile on the t-shirt and
leggings that Nikki was wearing on the
night she was murdered
whilst not as specific as autosomal DNA
the ystr DNA profile was nonetheless
discriminating
Mr Chapman the forensic scientist who
gave evidence before this jury accepted
that the ystr DNA profile found on
Nikki's clothing was not necessarily
unique to you
it would have been shared by any male
relative of yours but the police
investigation effectively ruled out the
possibility of another male relative
being in the Sunderland area in October
of 1992.
Mr Chapman also accepted that your why
sgr profile might be shared
coincidentally by other males
the chances of that coincidental sharing
may have been in the order of around 1
to 28 000.
but the jury had to consider what chance
there was of an unrelated man
coincidentally sharing your ystr DNA
profile
living within your local community
knowing Nikki Allen sufficiently well to
be able to lure her away from the Gulf
and who also knew the old Exchange
building so well that they were able to
navigate their way around in the dark
the DNA evidence was powerful evidence
against you
a review of other witness evidence
demonstrated inconsistencies in the
accounts which you had given the police
and showed that the that your Alibi
which you'd given yourself in your
police statement must have been false
this led to your arrest and charge
the discovery of Nikki's dead body
and the long search for her killer how
shocked and bewildered this community
for the past 31 years
the long search for Nikki Allen's killer
culminated in your conviction for the
murder of her on the 12th of May of
2023.
Nikki Allen was loved
she was loved by her mother whose moving
statement of loss and sadness has been
read to the court this morning by Mr
Wright King's Council
was loved by her father whose life was
changed by the events of the 7th of
October of 1992
she has left a hole in her family and in
the community in which she lived
I now sentenced you for her murder
there is only one sentence which I can
impose for the crime of murder and that
is one of life imprisonment
I must however go on to consider whether
to make a whole life order or to make a
minimum term order that is a minimum
term which you must serve before
consideration is given by the parole
board to your release
I must have regard to the general
principles set out in schedule 21 of the
sentencing act 2020 when deciding
whether to impose a whole life term or
when fixing the minimum term which you
must serve
your offense was committed before the
18th of December 2003
this makes a significant difference to
the approach which I must take to
sentence
paragraph 12 to the scheduled 21 of the
sentencing act 2020 requires me to have
regard to and indeed to apply the
practice which would have been followed
by the Secretary of State before 2002 in
respect of the term to be served in
prison
the law prevents me from making an order
which is greater than that which would
have been imposed had you been convicted
before December 2003.
this principle which I must follow
should be clearly understood
I emphasize that at this stage because
as will become apparent minimum terms to
be served before consideration is given
to release on license where in the 1990s
and the early 2000s much shorter than
would have been ordered today in 2023
in deciding whether to impose a minimum
term and if so the length of that term
before any release on license I'm
required to adopt the following approach
first to assess the term to be served by
reference to contemporary principles set
out in schedule 21 of the sentence act
I must then identify the length of that
minimum term before any release on
license as would have been determined by
the Secretary of State before 2002 by
applying the relevant practice
directions and other guidance available
if the minimum term to be served would
have been shorter before December 2002
then I must apply that shorter term
relevant findings of fact I start
therefore by considering the appropriate
term which you must serve by reference
to schedule 21 of the sentencing Act
in this context I make the following
findings of which I am sure having been
the trial judge
you lured Nikki Allen away from the
relative safety of the guards by telling
her lies
only you know what you said to her to
cause her to leave the garths with you
shortly before 10 pm on the 7th of
October 1992 but somehow you tricked her
into going with you in the opposite
direction to her home and on a cold and
dark night
you did not use Force a witness saw you
both on your way to the old Exchange
building you leading the way and Nikki
skipping along after you the impression
of that Witness
was that you were father and daughter
you didn't need to use Force because
Nikki knew you and she trusted you
the jury heard evidence that Nikki was
shy and clingy to her mother
not a child who would have been inclined
to go off with a stranger
but you knew Nikki's family and they
knew you
your purpose in luring Nikki away to the
old Exchange building was sexual
you intended to sexual assault Nikki
either in the grounds of the old
Exchange building or in the building
itself
you were age 25 at the time Nikki was
seven years old there could have been no
benign reason for your wishing to trick
Nikki into going with you to an isolated
derelict building
using Common Sense there could be no
other reason for you luring her away as
you did for anything other than a sexual
reason
my confidence in this conclusion is
fortified by my knowledge of your
history of convictions for offenses of
indecency towards children of Mickey's
age and by your admission to the
probation worker in March of 2000 that
in your early 20s you were sexually
interested in Children of Nikki's age
Nikki did not submit to the sexual
assault or attempted sexual assault she
must have resisted
and during the struggle her anarachan
shoes came off she screamed and you
struck her to silence her
you murdered her intending to kill her
in order that she would not tell anyone
about what she had done or had tried to
do to her
you pushed her into the deserted and
derelict building and then went in after
her
having struck Nikki over the head at
least twice with a brick fracturing her
skull you then stamped her chest with a
knife either a kitchen knife or a pen
knife which he had taken with you
your attack was brutal you stabbed
Nikki's chest and abdomen on 37
occasions the stab wounds were deep many
penetrating more than one internal organ
the t-shirt which Nikki was wearing bore
no holes
indicating that the T-shirt had been
raised above her abdomen when you
stabbed her
I cannot be sure that you deliberately
and intentionally raised her top
rather than it having become a rocked up
under her armpits during the struggle
I'm not there for sure that the act of
stabbing Nikki's naked chest had an
overtly sexual element to it
you cause Nikki great mental suffering
in the minutes before her loss of
consciousness
after you pushed her into the old
Exchange building she must have quickly
known that you were coming after her to
hurt her and there was nowhere for for
her to hide she was in a cold pitch
black building her Terror at what was to
befall her as you stalked her in that
building is unimaginable
you then took steps to conceal what
you've done you did your best to hide
Nikki's Body by dragging her down into
the dark Cellar where you dumped her in
the far corner of the room furthest away
from the staircase
no one would have been likely to have
found her body had they not been looking
for it in the cellar with a decent torch
he then covered Yourself by giving false
information to the police he provided
yourself with a neat but false Alibi
claiming to have been away from the
garth's getting fish and chips for a
friend at the time when Nikki was killed
you're now 55 years old when you
committed this murder you were 23 years
old
you appeared before the court on 22
occasions for 45 offenses
the majority of your offending has been
acquisitive
but your sexual attraction to
seven-year-old Nikki Allen was not an
isolated incident
in October 1986 you had been found to
have breach the peace when you had
approached a group of little girls
between 8 and 10 years old you took hold
of one girl by the arm and asked to kiss
her
you tell the children not to tell anyone
in March 2000 so eight years after your
killing of Nikki Allen you were
convicted of an indecent assault upon a
female under 14 years
two girls aged nine and twelve were
playing in a park
you approached the girls and took hold
of the shoulder of one of them
you told her not to scream
you asked the others whether she had
knickers at the other whether she had
knickers on
you then took hold of the front of her
clothing placed your hand between her
legs touching her vagina over her
clothing
in connection with this offense he were
interviewed by a probation officer
when you admitted that when you had been
approximately 22 years old or
thereabouts you had started to fantasize
about both adults and children in
particular young girls
you told her that you would think about
young girls being naked and what it
would be like to touch their body and
have sexual intercourse with them
it's against this background that I
addressed the first issue which I must
consider under schedule 21 of the
sentencing Act 2020.
not concerns whether to impose a whole
life order
paragraph two of schedule 21 provides
for a starting point of a whole life
term
in cases of exceptionally High
seriousness
paragraph 2 2 provides that cases which
would normally fall within this category
of exceptionally High seriousness
include a b
the murder of a child if it if it
involves the Abduction of the child or
it involves sexual motivation
in this case the crown does not submit
that Nikki was abducted by force
as I've said you were seen by Witnesses
apparently she was seen by Witnesses
apparently skipping behind you in order
to catch you up
but undoubtedly you tricked Nikki by
lying to her about something or other
you took advantage of our young age and
her naivety and of the fact that she
knew you and trusted you as a friend of
the family
I agree with Mr Wright that even though
no physical abduction took place your
use of deception to lure Nikki to the
old Exchange building approximates to
the abduction scenario
The Killing did not involve sexual
motivation I find no evidence that you
were sexually thrilled by The Killing
but the whole purpose of your tricking
Nikki to go to the derelict building was
as I have found in order to assault her
sexually
the presence of these factors in
conjunction with other factors which
I've identified in my findings of fat
have caused me to reflect very carefully
upon whether this is one of those
exceptional cases in which a whole life
order should be imposed
Mr Wright does not urge that course upon
me
and on reflection rightly so
recent guidance on the court of appeal
reminds judges that whole life orders
should be imposed only where the facts
of the case considered as a whole will
leave the judge in no doubt that the
offender must be kept in prison for the
rest of his or her life
it's a sentence of Last Resort for cases
of the most extreme gravity and one
reserved for a few exceptionally serious
cases
given this perspective whilst
undoubtedly a murder which will horrify
all those who hear or read about it I'm
not able to come to the shore and
confident conclusion that the imposition
of a whole life term for the murder of
Nikki Allen is appropriate
I am however wholly satisfied that the
murder of Nikki Allen was one of
particularly High seriousness as
envisaged by paragraph 3 of schedule 21
and the correct starting point for the
minimum term to be served is one of 30
years
paragraph three of schedule 21 sets out
a list of features which are present
would normally lead to the conclusion
that the murder falls into the category
are particularly High seriousness
it's a non-exhaustive list of examples
only
the real question for me is whether
reflecting on the types of conduct
referred to in those statutory examples
I am satisfied that there exist features
of your murder of Nikki Allen which
Justified that description of Nikki's
murder as one of particularly High
seriousness
and I am entirely satisfied that those
features do exist
I've already stated my conclusion that
whilst you didn't physically abduct
Nikki what you did by tricking a
trusting seven-year-old girl into going
with you was very close to such a
scenario that factor it seems to me is
one that I can and must take into
account when considering the seriousness
of the murder
I also take into account that your
purpose and luring Nikki away from the
gas was to sexually assault her and that
this is what you did
or at least tried to do when in the
scrub land around the building
one of the examples of factors which
would normally justify the inclusion of
the murder within the classification of
particular seriousness is that the
murder involves sexual conduct
that I find was not present in this case
I can't be sure that you deliberately
lifted Nikki's t-shirt up so as to
expose her chest
and all that there was sexual conduct
involved in The Killing itself
however the facts of Nikki's murder come
very close indeed to involving sexual
conduct and that your purpose in luring
her away with sexual and I have found
that you did sexy or assault her or at
least attempt to do so outside the
building
again this it seems to me is a factor
which I can and must take into account
when considering the starting point for
the minimum term which you should serve
finally I take into account your purpose
in killing Nikki
to prevent her telling anyone what
you've done
this does not come within the
description of a murder to obstruct or
interfere with the cause of justice as
stated in paragraph 3-2 no court of
justice have been set in motion by the
time you killed Nikki
but nonetheless it appears to me that
the purpose of your killing Nikki is a
factor which I can take into account
albeit to a very modest degree when
considering the starting point for the
minimum term
presence therefore of these three
features drive me to the inescapable
conclusion that your murder of Nikki
Allen must be categorized as one of
particular seriousness
each of the features which I have
identified approximate to various
statutory examples in paragraph three
two
Mr Pitter urges me not to reach this
conclusion on the basis that I can't be
sure that the murder Bears any of the
features which are mentioned in
paragraph three two but he poses the
wrong question of the Court the question
is not whether the facts of any murder
can be shoehorned into one of the
examples in paragraph three two but
whether taking the range of examples
into account the court can be sure that
the murder is one properly described as
of particular seriousness
from that starting point of 30 years I
then considered the aggravating factors
there are many
Mr Peter urges me to avoid the double
counting of these aggravating factors
and I agree with the need for caution in
this regard I accept just by way of
example that the use of two weapons
overlaps with the vicious nature of your
attack upon Nikki
however viewed cumulatively and guarding
against double counting the aggravating
factors justify a very significant
increase from the starting point of 30
years
the aggravating factors are as follows
the mental and physical suffering which
Nikki Allen experienced before you kill
her this Bears repetition
I take into accounts here that that
period of mental suffering which he must
have experienced after you've pushed her
into the derelict building
she must have quickly known that she was
trapped
she must have quickly known that you
were coming after her to hurt her it was
cold and dark
I can't be sure of the time which you
took to stalk her in that building it
may have been a short time only but
however long it was it must have been a
truly terrifying experience for this
seven-year-old girl
I also take into account here what
happened outside the building before you
pushed her inside it there was clearly
some sort of struggle after your assault
or attempted assault and one which Nikki
was bound to lose and I don't
underestimate how frightening this
experience must have been for her
the further aggravating factor is your
use of two weapons a brick and a knife
which you took to the scene
in addressing me on the application of
schedule 21 Mr Pisa
urges me to find that not only is
paragraph 3 not engaged but noise
paragraph four
Mr Pitter argues that the knife which
you carried was not one which was taken
to the scene in the technical sense
intended to be conveyed by paragraph
four
I reject this submission I am sure that
you took a knife with you to the
building and that you intended when you
were there to commit an offense of
sexual assault and or have that knife
available as a weapon it's not disputed
that you use the weapon in committing
the murder of Mickey Allen paragraph
four is therefore engaged
this finding is however overtaken by my
earlier conclusion that this is a murder
of particular seriousness However the
fact that a life was taken even a pen
life and it was used represents a
significant aggravating factor which I
must take into account
a further aggravating factor is the
vicious and brutal nature of your attack
upon Nikki involving two blows at least
to the head and over 30 stamps to her
body
further aggravating factor is your
attempt to conceal the body by placing
her in a distant room in the basement
and finally your statement to the police
whilst this was made after George Herron
had been charged with Nikki's murder
nonetheless you are providing a
statement in which you gave yourself a
false Alibi whilst another person was
tried for the murder which you had
committed
I must of course consider such
mitigation as may exist
there is none
your Council urges me to take into
account your IQ which Falls within the
extremely low range placing you in the
bottom two percent of the general
population
I accept the content of the report
prepared on your behalf by Dr Harry wood
a psychologist who describes your mild
learning difficulties and a degree of
intellectual impairment
however I am unable to accept that the
content of that report in any respect is
relevant to the minimum term which I
must impose
any intellectual difficulties which you
face do not affect your culpability for
this offense you demonstrated quite
sufficient guile to lure Nikki away from
the garths and you are quick to attempt
to cover your tracks by inventing a
false Alibi which you gave to the police
nor do I accept that your age then or
now is a relevant Factor mitigating in
your favor
at the time of this murder you were an
adult of 25 you were not a child or an
adolescent who knew no better
you're now aged 55 years the fact that
as a result of the minimum term which I
may impose you may die in prison is not
it seems to me a factor which I should
take into account
therefore taking all of these factors
into account the minimum term which I
would have ordered under schedule 21 is
one of not less than 37 years
move on to stage two
of my assessment which is the home
secretary's determination
I must now determine what the decision
of the Home Secretary would have been
before 2002 by applying the applicable
guidance at the time
on the 10th of February of 1997 a letter
was sent by Lord Bingham
to all judges who made recommendations
as to the appropriate term in murder
cases
that letter
advocated 14 years
as the normal penalty for the average or
normal or unexceptional murder
before taking aggravating and mitigating
factors into account
the letter went on to list the various
factors which would likely call for a
sentence mitigating the normal penalty
those factors included subnormality or
mental abnormality
and spontaneity or lack of premeditation
beyond that necessary to constitute the
events
for example a sudden response to family
pressure or to prolong stress
Lord Bingham listed the following
factors as likely to call for a sentence
more severe than the norm
they included the killing of a child
or a very old or otherwise vulnerable
victim
evidence of sadism gratuitous violence
or sexual maltreatment humiliation or
degradation before The Killing
and the use of firearm Firearms or other
dangerous weapons whether carried for
defensive or offensive reasons
they're being a remarked that whilst a
recommendation of a punitive term longer
than say 30 years will be very rare
indeed I don't think one should set any
upper limit some crimes will certainly
call for terms very well in excess of
the norm
clear from the text of the Bingham
letter that Lord Bingham was not himself
setting the Tariff rather he was
reflecting his own judicial experience
and that of other judges in describing
the level of minimum terms which are
being imposed at the time of writing
the practice Direction assist issued in
said that in sentences where the murder
was committed before the 31st of May
2002 the best guide to what would have
been the practice of the Secretary of
State
uh is the letters sent to judges by Lord
Bingham of Corn Hill the Lord Chief
Justice in February of 1997.
I mentioned a further practice Direction
which was issued in 2002 by Lord Wolff
although of narrowed date application
that practice Direction refined the
starting points for the minimum terms to
be imposed
the range extended from
A reduced starting point of eight to
nine years for a case with reduced
responsibility
a starting point of 12 years for a
normal murder for example one involving
a case involving the death of an adult
victim arising from a quarrel or loss of
temper between two people known to each
other
a higher starting point of 15 to 16
years for more serious cases
for especially grave cases for example
those involving what was described as a
sexual murder or the murder of a young
child a term of 20 years or upwards
would be appropriate
a term of 30 years
existed for an extremely serious case
the practice Direction stated that a
substantial upward adjustment may be
appropriate in the most serious cases
for example those involving a
substantial number of murders or if
there are several factors identified as
a tract in the highest starting point
present
in suitable cases the result might even
be a minimum term of 30 years
and the categorization maintained the
possibility of no minimum term being
imposed for cases of exceptional gravity
in effect the imposition of a whole life
term
these recommendations were considered by
the court of appeal in the 2004 case of
the crown Sullivan where the court found
there to be no inconsistency between
Lord bingham's advice and the Wolf
practice Direction
a paragraph 34 the court stated that
while a judge might be helped to be
consistent by the more specific guidance
contained in the 2002 directions their
General effect is the same
both give the judge a considerable
degree of discretion
would I take
from all of those materials is this
what was described
the ba normal or unexceptional murder
might attract a starting point for the
minimum term in the region of 14 years
for the murder of a child or a murder
associated with sexual conduct a
starting point of 20 years might be
appropriate
term of 30 years will be reserved for an
extremely serious case
and the imposition of such a minimum
term would be a rare event
in cases of exceptional gravity a whole
life term may be imposed
and finally in all cases of which a
minimum term was to be imposed the court
retained considerable discretion to take
account of aggravating or mitigating
factors which relate to either the
offense or the offender in the
particular case
it's in this context that I must stand
back and examine your offending and
determine where within the range of
starting points the court would have
placed that offending and what the
effect of the many aggravating factors
would have been
both Council agree that this is a case
in which before December 2002 a minimum
term of at least 20 years would have
been appropriate
Mr Wright submits that there should have
been a significant there would have been
and should have been then a significant
increase to reflect the multiple
aggravating factors
Mr Pitter that that should be little or
no increase from 20 years at all
I'm entirely satisfied that before
December 2002 a minimum term well in
excess of 20 years would have been
imposed
Lord Bingham identified the killing of a
child
evidence of sexual maltreatment for the
killing and the use of a weapon all a
separate aggravating factors all three
were present in your case
even from a starting point of 14 years
these factors would have increased the
term substantially in my judgment to a
point at all Beyond 20 years
the court would then have to reflect
upon the further aggravating factors
which I've described elsewhere
there were in reality no mitigating
factors
although Mr Peter again relies upon your
youth at the time of the offense I
reject that submission you were 25 years
old
the possibility that you may have died
in prison or emerged an old man would
not have Arisen in 1992
even if as Mr Pitter submits I must take
the position as it is today I'm still
unable to accept that the possibility
that you may die in prison is a factor
which in any material way serves to
reduce the minimum term
the murder of Nikki Allen involved the
cynical manipulation of a young
seven-year-old girl who you lured away
from her home at night for the purpose
of sexually assaulting her
you attacked her twice once inside the
outside the old Exchange building and
then the Fatal assault your fatal
assault the Fatal assault was brutal
you must have inflicted upon her
unimaginable Terror in the period before
that fatal assault you then took steps
to cover your tracks by hiding the body
to the extent that you could within that
building and by advance in your false
Alibi whilst another person stood trial
for the murder which you had committed
I consider having a regard to all of
those factors that you're offending was
so serious that a minimum term of no
less than 29 years would have been
imposed
any term less than this would not have
reflected the recommendation of the
trial judge or the decision of the Home
Secretary at the time
I've given serious consideration to the
conclusion the combination of
aggravating factors would have led to
the imposition of a term of 30 years or
more
however taking into consideration the
observations of Lord Bingham that the
imposition of such a term would be very
rare indeed I've concluded that I can't
be sure that a term in excess of 30
years would have been imposed
accordingly I'm satisfied and fined that
the minimum term of imprisonment which
would have been ordered which would have
been ordered that you serve before
release on license is 29 years
that being lower than the minimum term I
have determined under the Contemporary
regime I set the minimum term as one of
29 years subject to the consideration of
the time he was spent on demand which is
366 days
I remind all of those listening that the
minimum term is just that
a minimum term which cannot be reduced
in any way
after those 29 years have been served
there is no guarantee that you would be
released
it's only if the parole board decides
that you are fit to be released that you
will be released and even then you will
be subject to license and recall if you
breach the terms of your license
David Boyd stand up
for the murder of Nikki Allen on the 7th
of October of 1992 the sentence of the
court is one of life imprisonment
you will serve term of 29 years subject
to the 366 days which you have spent on
demand before consideration is given to
your release by the parole board
if you take him down
um it's Justice Lambert they're
sentencing David Boyd to life in prison
with a minimum term of 29 years for the
murder of seven-year-old Nikki Allen in
Sunderland in 1992 apologies once again
to our viewers for anything that you may
have heard during those sentencing
remarks
which may have caused distress and
really upsetting detail there as the
judge went over what David Boyd did back
in 1992 our correspondent shinki marike
has been following uh this story he is
outside Newcastle Crown Court for us so
life in prison a minimum term of 29
years before David Bowie Chingy will be
considered for parole
that's right David Boyd may die in
prison he has been sentenced to life of
a minimum term of 29 years for the
murder of Nikki Allen in 1992 and just
coming back to those events it's one of
the most notorious crimes that have
taken place in recent memory in the
Northeast David Boyd lured her away from
the block of flats that they both lived
in he was essentially to try to
attempting to sexually assault her that
didn't go to plan he struck her on the
head with a brick then he pulled her
into a derelict building and stabbed her
in the chest 37 times and an act of
brutality which shocked the community
and obviously impacted her family deeply
and in court her mother Sharon was there
in tears at points struggling with the
weight of what was going on the weight
of our emotions looking at this man
finally being sentenced to life after
her three-decade campaign for justice
and over the course of the day we heard
her Victim Impact statement where she
talked about the toll that this
campaigning has taken on her this
fighting for justice is in that she said
that by murdering Nikki David Boyd has
destroyed not only Nikki's life the life
of my beautiful daughter my life and the
lives of my daughters and grandchildren
we have not been able to live normal
lives since that day and that just goes
to show the impact it's had on them we
also had a statement from her father
saying similar things about how when he
goes to funerals he can't bear to bring
himself there because he thinks about
the death of Nikki this is of course an
a set of circumstances and a case which
has thrown the spotlight on northumbria
police who dealt with it because their
original investigation was riddled with
mistakes they first of all charged the
wrong man George Herron in 1993 before
reopening the investigation in 2017 and
then arresting David Boyd in 2018 thanks
to advances in DNA and forensics that
allowed them to find traces of his DNA
on her clothing like I say at long last
for Nikki Allen's family they now have
Justice in the form of David Boyd being
sentenced to life in prison
uh shingy thank you Mariko there with
the latest from Newcastle Crown Court
that sentencing happening just a few
minutes ago detective Chief
superintendent Lisa tika has been
telling us of her relief that Nikki's
killer has finally been Cornwall over
three decades after her murder
there are a number of emotions but I
think the overwhelming one for me is
that of relief and relief in particular
for Sharon and her family and that
finally we have brought the person
responsible for Nikki's murder to
Justice
and a large chunk of that success is
down to those advances in forensics that
made this possible just tell us a bit
more about those and how they aided you
in the case yeah so the new forensic
techniques have been absolutely key in
this investigation so I first became the
sio of this investigation in 2016 and it
was at that point where I've worked with
the scientist in this case James Chapman
to try and look at some opportunities to
help us identify who was responsible and
that's been a long process we had some
success in February 2017 where we
identified a profile but at that point
we didn't know who it belonged to so
that's when the investigation started in
a Earnest really to identify who it
belonged to so we had an initial group
of people from the original
investigation there was 212 men and that
we went about taking samples from
um and indeed David Boyd was number 54.
so we went to visit David Boyd in
October 4th of October and took his
sample
um and then the third of November we
managed to identify that it was David
Boyd
and tell us a bit about the public
corporation involved in this I
understand that there were samples taken
from within the community as well just
tell us a bit about that how people
reacted responded and assisted yeah the
community and residents in Sunderland
have been outstanding and have been
really really helpful and supportive and
they have played their part in this
investigation we went to see hundreds of
men that live in Sunderland to obtain a
voluntary sample of their DNA and they
gave their DNA and and without that
truth be told we would have struggled in
this investigation because a big part of
this for us has been to show that it
couldn't have been anybody else and to
satisfy ourselves that it was David Boyd
and him alone that murdered Nikki Allen
and having been the senior investigating
officer on this case you would have been
thinking about family and the impact
it's having then throughout all this
time what are your Reflections on that
the fact that we have someone who would
have been fully blunted out now
living her life taken from her family
yeah it's um it's heartbreaking and you
know I've spent time over the years
speaking to Sharon and there's moments
where I can see where she's looking at
me and she's wanting answers but I can't
give her the answers partly because I
couldn't share some of the information
from the investigation
um so it's it's been really hard for
Sharon for David Nikki's dad and the
rest of the family to have to wait for
so long and and when you know we would
go and visit Sharon and try to explain
and give reasons why it's taken so long
that that's been really difficult as
well because you can see and absolutely
understand her frustration and the fact
that she's lost trust in the police
northumbria police's reaction to the
breaking news this afternoon that David
Boyd has been sentenced to life in
prison this afternoon with a minimum
term of 29 years that's for the murder
of seven-year-old Nikki Allen in 1992
representative from northumbria police
they're going into some detail as to how
it took over 30 years for him to be
brought to Justice let's bring in our
correspondent shingy marike who is
following this story for us outside of
Newcastle Crown Court Chingy we are
expecting to hear um from the family's
legal team shortly uh representing Nikki
Allen's family and but it's worth just
reminding you is why it took 30 years
for David Boyd to be brought to Justice
it was all to do with new DNA techniques
that came in during that time
yeah that's right advances in forensics
that detectives have spoken to me about
are part of the reason why they're able
to bring David boy to justice but there
was a different tone to the second
investigation so rather than jumping the
gun and jumping to conclusions and
charging someone quickly even after they
had arrested David Boyd there took their
time and went through a careful process
of elimination to ensure that he was the
right person and that's quite important
they knew that the family were upset
without the first investigation went and
the community as well were also
disturbed by what happened and the
impact on George Herron's life and we
had a sense of that last week because
speaking to northumbria police they
released a letter which they had sent to
him apologizing his life essentially
irreparably damaged as he had to move
away from the area their allegations
that he was attacked also apart during
the time period that that happened and
his life also one that's been damaged by
what happened in this case so as I say
this investigation took on a very
different tone in which the forensics
were the focus followed by a careful
process of elimination until they were
confident that David Boyd was the person
that they wanted to bring to Justice
in the judge's sentencing remarks today
the the toll it's taken on Nikki Allen's
family particularly her mother who never
gave up her quest to find who murdered
her little girl
foreign
yeah that's right she never gave up and
I think at points in court it was almost
overwhelming for her to sit in there
first part in the morning she didn't
come in but when the sentencing was
handed down she brought herself into the
court and looked at David Boyd at points
but it would have been incredibly hard
for her just to give you a sense of the
impact it's had on her there are points
where she had been arrested for trying
to make her own make her own kind of
dents in an investigation she's also
checked in and out of mental health
hospitals this has made living difficult
for her she said that her life and the
lives of her daughters and her
grandchildren are never the same I've
never been the same because there was a
hole in their life and I think another
thing to potentially think about is the
fact that coming back to the
investigation you mentioned and the
failure is there David Boyd lived in the
same block of flats in Sunderland as the
family in fact he was around three doors
down from uh from Nikki's grandparents
and yet he wasn't treated as a suspect
in the first investigation he was
treated as a witness there was a picture
of David Boyden his twenties which the
prosecution have since said matched an
e-fit of someone who was seen by a
witness at the time walking with a young
girl the night Nikki died so as much as
the family will be happy to have David
Boyd behind bars for those 29 years
they're also be raising points about
flaws in the investigation and ways in
which this could have been better and
we're waiting to hear from them very
shortly
there with the latest from Newcastle
Crown Court we are expecting as I said
to hear
um from the lawyer representing um Nikki
Allen's family a little bit later this
afternoon we'll bring that to you as
soon as it happens here on Sky News
reacting to that breaking news that
David Boyd has been sentenced today to
life in prison with a minimum term of 29
years for young Nikki Allen's murder in
1992.
our other main news story this afternoon
it's been announced that the disgraced
TV presenter Rolf Harris has died at the
age of 93. the former entertainment
artist and musician was convicted of
child sex offenses back in 2014. we
understand he died 13 days ago after
being diagnosed with neck